Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. This will be my Full
Loki Season 2 Episode 5 video
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references, so we'll break it all down.
Your brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'll start talking more about Loki Season
3 and what Kevin Feige
said about the future of the show
as we get closer to the finale.
but a lot of this is meant to influence
what's happening in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
I just did a video too
about Marvel's behind the scenes plans
and how they might be changing things in Dr.
Doom might become a much bigger villain
figure in the future.
The Avengers movies after Kang Dynasty instead
of their previous plans to use Jonathan Majors.
apparently during the Loki finale,
there'll be some moment that they end on that
gives them more information
about Marvel's path forward.
it just means that things are going to get even
crazier as we get closer to the finale.
Rosa doing a giveaway for Loki Blu rays?
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and you start posting all your theories
about how they're going to get out of this one,
because it does seem like
they're going to replay the events
from previous episodes.
But Loki will do things in a different way this time
to try and stop the timeline from exploding.
but before we get too deep into the weeds.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet, we'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments.
Lot of WTF moments in this episode,
starting with the episode title
Science Fiction, which is written like a reference
to a section in a bookstore
because of the XR tent contingent book
that Oren Burrows gets at the bookstore revealing.
It was a plot by him.
It was a science fiction book that he wrote
and tried to plant in the store
to try and drum up more sales like,
look how popular it is.
People want it.
You should order more copies,
which itself is meant to be a joke
on the whole idea of the TV manual
and his relationship with Victor.
Timely like Victor
Timely initially gave him the ideas
to create the TBS manual,
but then the TBS manual also influenced
Victor timely in the past, causing him to come up
with some of those ideas in the first place.
so it was meant to be a reference back
to the whole concept of the horrible
rose of the snake eating its tail,
the timeline repeating, so to speak.
it's also meant to be a reference to or a borrows
explaining to Loki why he was time slipping.
Like, is it a science problem
or is it a fiction problem in the differences
between those two, like science is all about
what in how in fiction is all about? Why?
Why is Loki time slipping In reality
though, the solution to that problem
like the
why how or what was actually more of a who problem.
but we'll talk more about that
when we get to that part of the episode.
It's also a bit of a doctor
who reference to like him
talking about who quote unquote,
because this season of Loki is very much like Doctor
Who The opening scene starts with that strange
ethereal music over the opening Marvel titles.
It sounds kind of like the soundtrack from 2001
A Space Odyssey, when he's traveling
through the Stargate and he's moving through space
and time because that's kind of what Loki is doing.
Aura Borrows also says that he's kind of turned in
to like a raw version of a tempered White
light flashes.
You hear sirens.
They reveal that Loki has been time slipping,
and he just doesn't realize what's happening
at first he winds up jumping a little bit forward
in the timeline.
When the TVA itself starts to break
down, everybody's evacuated.
That's where there's nobody in the building
like he's walking through the hallways,
but nobody else is there.
there's a female voice on the comm system,
and it's actually
Tara Strong reading the dialog,
but it's not her doing her Ms.
Minutes Voice If you didn't realize
Tara Strong is the voice of Ms.
Minutes,
Hey, y'all.
How y'all doing?
It's been a minute.
Just wanted to check in
and make sure y'all doing okay.
if you haven't seen the season finale, lucky
you can still be framed.
she's reading off a TVA failsafe code one, two,
two nine is basically the idea that the TVA
is about to be destroyed.
So it's basically like the last warning that the TVA
gives out is everything is about to be destroyed.
there's also the sad
sounding music playing on the comm system.
When she's reading that,
it sounds kind of like the music
the band kept on playing
when the Titanic was sinking
because it's kind of what's happening with the TVA
right now, only a sinking into nothingness
because everything's being spaghetti ified.
There'll be a lot of references
to spaghetti during the episode
because most stuff gets turned into spaghetti
at some point.
then as he starts time slipping again
in a much bigger way,
the voice says, Thank you for your service,
which is also the Ms.
Minutes message that reads on the monitor
as everything turns into spaghetti later
he passes the empty interrogation room
that we just saw everybody die in our ship.
moment is showing us what the face of true evil
actually looks like in the MCU.
You thought the Thanos was bad.
No, no, no. This is worse.
he Time slips to the control room.
He sees another version of himself
reading the TVA manual.
Just as he greets him, he time slips again quickly
with the other version, not seeing him in time.
We later replay these events
it is meant to be a reference to the way time works
and how he later learns to control the ability
and also kind of does the same thing with Mobius,
basically showing Mobius
a time displaced version of what just happened.
Let's see,
you can actually come back here any time you want.
there's a normal version of you
basically turning Mobius into a variant.
Don't worry, I'll get to that too,
because it pays off a big Easter egg
from their conversation in the Automat earlier
about how Mobius wound up in the TVA
in the first place to begin with,
they basically confirmed that Loki is the mystery
figure that took into the TVA in the first place.
he basically time slips again
and winds up being the other person.
That equation
like he winds up going to the control room.
The old fashioned way reading from the manual.
And then he sees the same events replay themselves.
But from the other perspective
just as everything turns into spaghetti
and they read that same message that you just heard
on the comm system, thank you for your service.
R.I.P. TVA.
then during the normal Loki intro
with like the normal Loki titles,
they play a clock themed version of the Loki theme
song, like it's
a ticking clock, basically being a metaphor for
what's actually happening in the last two episodes.
Like there is a ticking clock.
So to speak, on everything
winding up, being destroyed.
Then we start going around
to the different timelines.
He starts time slipping and seeing everyone
in their original lives, starting with Casey.
in it turns out that his original life
was actually the person
that the movie escaped from Alcatraz
that Clint Eastwood made was based on.
He's actually the real version of Clint Eastwood's
character, Frank.
some of you
probably realize what was going on here before
they actually revealed the time period in the place.
So that basically gave it away
like, San Francisco, 1962.
that's when The Escape from Alcatraz
movie was supposed to take place.
the way that he and his friends escape from Alcatraz
mirrors the way that they escape during the movie.
If you haven't seen the movie, it's a classic.
I would recommend checking it out.
Really cool prison break movie.
in it's actually based on real life events.
So like they're saying that Casey was
the real person who the movie was actually based on.
the only thing about this
and everyone else's original lives is
these are all happening in branch timelines,
not on the sacred timeline.
So these are all meant
to be variants of the character,
which is why they eventually got pruned
and taken to the TVA.
They came from
timelines were variants of Kang Rose up,
which is why originally he who remains wanted
to prevent these branches from growing out.
like I said,
they revealed that Casey's original name was Frank.
That's the name of the character the Clint Eastwood
played in The Escape from Alcatraz movie.
His friends are named Clarence. One is John.
Those are the names of his friends during the movie.
he makes a joke reference to the events
of Loki season one, when he says if they get caught,
they're going to be gut like fish,
which is what Loki told him at the TVA.
it basically the rest of the episode is dedicated
to Loki putting the band back together,
so to speak, putting the pins back in the cup,
jumping around to all the different branch timelines
to try and get everyone back.
they're couple time slips.
He jumps to Sylvie's McDonald's quickly,
then to Mobius Jet ski dealership
confirming a lot of our theories and teasers
from season one and season two.
Mobius was originally a jet ski salesman,
which is why
he was so obsessed with them
and why he knew so much about them.
the only thing about Mobius, his original life here
is that it's actually in the year 2022,
not in the nineties. Like a lot of us believed.
Then he jumps to one of the interrogation rooms
where Mobius interrogated him in season one.
And if it wasn't clear, like Zoom, an enhanced
look in the back, the number 25 room here,
this is the exact same room
that they used during season one episode one
The music that plays inside the room
here is the same music.
When he watched the highlight reel
from the life of the original 616,
Loki watching himself be killed by Thanos.
the next place they go is the Hunter B-15,
the original life.
She's also in a brains
timeline in the year 2012 in New York City.
That's the year that the Avengers movie happened.
So it's like they're saying that she was there
during the Battle of New York when it was going down
in. Apparently she's
just a normal pediatrician, doctor treating a child.
she briefly sees Loki times slipping, but they don't
really jump back to her till later in the episode
we get to see Mobius actually riding a jet ski
getting all pumped up
and it's like they're fulfilling
a lot of fan art wishes out there.
Like there's so much fan
art of him on jet skis from season one.
They're finally paying that off now
he's from Cleveland, Ohio.
Like I said, in 2022, he has two different sons.
That's also a bit of a reference to Thor and Loki
and Odin.
I'll talk about that in a second
to their couple of jokes about him trying to talk
a customer out of buying a dirt bike
and into buying a jet ski.
He also does that later in the episode, too,
just like randomly trying to sell people on jet skis
wherever he goes.
Apparently they're the thinking man's dirt bike.
He references Poseidon.
Poseidon is the Greek god of the sea.
He's actually a character in the Marvel Universe.
The Greek gods exist in the MCU.
We saw them during Thor, Love and Thunder,
For example, Hercules is also part of that pantheon,
Then Loki time slips again back to the dealership
and unintentionally mimics the advertising blow up.
Though a lot of people saw behind the scenes
footage of this and had a theory that that's
what he was doing.
Like he was both times sloppy,
but he was also kind of mimicking the blowup doll
You also notice that the belt that he's wearing
is like a TVA belt buckle on it.
I'm sure at some point
Marvel will start selling that as merchandise
and basically his scenes with Mobius
play out the same way they play with Casey.
Like he's trying to convince him the same way.
But he makes all kinds of TVA jokes
like, No, no, no, you're talking about ATVs.
We got some of those last week.
ATVs are basically four wheelers
Then we jump to or a borrows his original life.
And they finally confirm with the czar
ten contingent was all about in those end credits
scenes.
There are a couple moments during the episode
that also reveal end credits scenes like,
this is where this was from.
And it turns out Zintan Contingent was a science
fiction book in a bookstore that he goes to buy it.
But he wrote the book himself, implanted
the book there to try and drum up more sales.
and it's meant to pay off the title
of the episode Science slash Fiction,
because that's the section of books
where he put his book.
they reveal or a borrows is from 1994
Pasadena, California here.
I think the 1994 time period
which just a reference to K Hui Quan in real life
Like at that point in real life,
he had just made the Encino Man movie.
If you don't remember, he was in that movie.
he started to act a little bit less and less
and started working more behind
the camera like he was the stunt coordinator
on the first X-Men movie in 2000.
This is a scene of him helping Hugh Jackman
during his Wolverine fight scenes in that movie,
talk about the whole concept to Ora Burrows in time
repeating now he is a marvel character
in a marvel project with Hugh Jackman,
who is also coming back as his Wolverine.
The circle of Easter eggs is now complete.
all the jokes here with them,
catching him, trying to buy his own book.
Like you need to stop putting your book
in this section here.
Like we told you not to do this.
it's meant to be a big reference
back to the whole concept of the TV
manual book in how his relationship with Victor
Timely works, like the idea that he wrote
the book based on Victor,
timely suggestions and his ideas.
But Victor Timely himself was influenced
by having a future copy of the book
that was what that little line of dialog was about.
Like, I hear this author is amazing.
I read all of his stuff,
but he himself is the author,
just another reference back to the whole concept
of or a burrows in the snake
eating his tale we go to his warehouse
which is in a remote area nearby.
It looks exactly like his workshop at the TVA
is full of sticky notes
and they reveal it's the same sticky notes
from the end credits scene.
So everybody wondered
who was making all these notes.
Turns out it was Obi.
they're also meant to be notes about his work
and his ideas for his books.
but the other interesting thing
though, is that a lot of these sticky notes
are references to things in Marvel movies
and Marvel TV shows.
sort of like this weird thing where he's dreaming up
the Marvel Universe for his books.
You know,
he's kind of remembering things from the TV,
but not quite I did a much bigger video
about some of the Easter eggs
here on all the different sticky notes back
when episode one came out.
So I'll link that video below
in the description. ba.
Like there are references to the events
of one division, Scarlet Witch, the Hex.
so there's a whole play.
On the idea of him
coming up with science fiction stories,
but they're based on things that will eventually
wind up happening to him in the future.
when Loki time slips in and finds him,
they have a joke about him being the only one
who's actually excited about what Loki is saying.
Like he believes on the spot.
you're clearly one of the characters
from my fictional books and you need help.
So I'm here to help you.
Like he doesn't question it at all.
when he says
he thinks that Loki is one of the characters
from his sons of your own book
that have come to life,
That's meant to be a reference to the idea of Thor
and Odin.
Like he and Thor are the sons of yore and like,
you're in, is Odin in this equation?
He reveals he considers his real job
to be that of a science fiction author.
But his day job just to pay
the bills was getting a Ph.D.
in theoretical physics.
And teaching is a professor at Caltech.
Like, that's just a side gig.
just like Mobius tries to sell people
on a bunch of jet skis throughout the episode.
He also tries to sell
Loki a copy of The Sons of your book.
Like, look, they're flying off the shelves.
You better get one quick.
then he basically goes full Charlie Day meme
trying to explain to Loki
how his current time slipping situation
works with it completely flying over Loki's head.
Like even though Loki is meant to be a very,
very intelligent person compared to someone say,
like Thor, he starts to lose Obie when they get into
the whole weeds of how time travel works.
like the whole metaphor
the OB uses is that Loki basically did
something that should have been impossible.
Like if time doesn't exist where you came from
because time basically blew up,
then you shouldn't have been able to time travel.
But if you did, it means that you could probably do
the same thing again.
basically a reference to him
being able to control his time slipping,
which it takes him a while
to figure out how to do in his OB that makes him
realize that his time slipping isn't as random
as it seems like
because he keeps time slipping to all the people
that he's been looking for and really the key
to being able to control
time slipping is focusing on his friends.
there are a couple references
to the Council of Kangs and Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty when Loki is explained to him
why they need to save the TVA.
Like if we don't save it, it'll be destroyed
and there'll be nothing to save us
from what is coming in.
The thing that is coming is the Council of Kangs.
like I said, apparently there's going to be a moment
at the end of Loki season two
that'll sort of explain how that's going to work
like that will lead into Avengers five.
a lot of people wondering what they're going to do
with Jonathan Majors
and the whole concept of the gangs.
They'll still be a big deal during Avengers five,
but the big question is whether or not
Marvel is going to move past that.
Four Avengers six secret wars and use a different
villain like, say, God, Emperor or Doom?
Apparently there'll be a moment,
the Loki finale, that will just clarify that Somehow
I have a feeling
that it won't be that clear. Like those.
There'll be so many questions
after Loki Season two is done.
When he tries and fails, the time slip on purpose.
That's meant to be a funny callback
to season one Episode one
when he also tried to use his magic and failed to do
so because of the magic dampeners
Loki whips out the TVA manual that he has on him,
gives it to Obi
so that he can construct
a homemade version of the TVA temple
so they can go around actively
and get everybody back together
it is meant to be another reference back
to that whole Victor timely scene where he meets Obi
and is like,
I came up with all these ideas
because of this journal,
you know, because like I wrote the journal
because of all your ideas, the whole idea
of the timeline
repeating or a burrow's concept itself,
this is a funny joke here about him
still being underappreciated in the future
when he says, Yeah, I finally wrote
a bestselling book because look, he's like,
yes, this is on every desk in the TVA,
this manual that you write.
in the TVA, they basically explained
that nobody ever bothers to read the manual,
which is like a joke on people in real life,
never reading manuals
when they want to put things together.
so even though he does make a book
that is super important,
nobody in the future ever actually winds up reading
except for Mike Casey and Victor timely.
they're like his only fanboys.
so he continues to be a very underappreciated genius
in the future.
Loki time slips to Mobius his house.
One of his kids action
figures, looks just like a TVA hunter in his armor
who is burnt, which could be a reference
to their recent battle in the TVA.
when we meet his sons.
I think this is meant to be a Loki in Thor metaphor.
Like one of his sons names is Kevin.
He's super mischievous,
like he's burning all the toys and he runs off.
The other son is named
Kevin. He's a little more responsible.
They have bikes that are both red
for Thor's red cape and green for Loki.
one of his sons wants a snake.
You could also call that a reference
to the funny story
that Thor told about
when he wanted a snake as a child.
And Loki turned himself into a snake to scare him.
just more meta references back to MCU things.
Mobius tries to sell a messy do out of his garage.
He reveals his divorce
like he says his wife is long gone.
You can theorize in the comments
about who you think that he was married to The Loki
quotes him his same speech about jetskis
that he gave during season one.
Then Obi exits a TVA portal
using his homemade tempered, claiming
Loki time slip 19 months into the future.
And that's how long it took him
to finish the device.
in while that was happening,
he also jokes that his wife left him to Andy,
lost his job because he was so obsessed
with the TVA manual in building this device.
So he stopped teaching his classes
in, stopped paying attention to his wife.
they're couple funny moments
with him in the background of all these next couple
of scenes, too, where you see
his portal is just like shifting all over.
Like it's kind of janky because it's super low fi,
like it's all homemade,
the portals aren't quite as stable
as the normal portal is from regular temp pads.
when he tells Mobius that he promises
that this will all make sense shortly.
He said the same thing to Sylvie
when he pruned himself
love, the whole call to action speech
that Loki gives to him too.
Like it's meant to show you how much Loki cares
about him and thinks of him as a friend.
I I feel like.
One of the strengths of the Loki show
above Some of the other Disney Plus Marvel shows
is just the character interactions.
Like they just have way better chemistry together
so you can just have scenes of them
talking to each other that are just as good as, say,
like the big action scenes
And basically this whole conversation him
bringing back to the TVA
meant to pay off the conversation
they had at the Automat, where Mobius wondered
who brought him to the TVA initially
because he didn't remember,
because he had his mind wiped in, how he'd thank him
if he ever saw the person.
And it was meant to be.
Loki like Loki is the person
who brought him to the TVA to begin with.
just another example
of the whole concept of Aura borrows
like getting back to the whole title of episode one
The snake eating its tail, in the reason
why Loki didn't remember that he did that here
is because this younger version of the character
had not done it yet.
Like he didn't get him from the past to begin with.
this is meant to be the initial moment
when he brought him to the TVA.
they also revealed
this is how Mobius got his name to like
Loki gave him the idea for the name,
which is how he came up with it in the first place.
later,
they do reveal that his original name was Don.
Then they get Hunter B-15 to come back.
Then Cassie and I love how he starts
stealing parts from around Obey's workshop.
Like he's getting ready to escape again
just because he's still in criminal mode.
then things start to get a little bit weird.
When he goes to pick up Sylvie at her McDonald's,
notice that her McDonald's turned to spaghetti
and disappears before she can see it
because everything in her brains
timeline is breaking down
just like everybody else is.
A branch timeline.
the reveal that unlike everyone else, Sylvie
remembers the timeline
exploding like literally everything up
to the last moments before
Episode five started at the bar
where they go to have a drink, they have a maniac
video game arcade
machine revealing in this universe, This ENIAC movie
that was filmed by Brad Wolf,
the Hunter X5 character in the past in the 1970s,
blew up really big
and they turned it into video games.
Remember, she's meant to be in 1982.
So it's a couple of years
after this ENIAC movie would have been released.
know I kind of actually
want to play a version of that game.
It sounds kind of like a beat him out game,
there were all conversation about whether or not
it's better that everyone got their old lives
back is just meant to lead Loki
to actually revealing what he really wants.
Like that's what she'll be confronted with.
Like,
what do you actually want in this life of yours,
this is meant to highlight
the whole theme of Loki season two in The Producers
basically said that it's Loki
trying to save his friends, his new family,
as he considers
them, basically questioning his purpose again.
Like, who am I if I have to live alone?
Like I want my friends back,
when they jump back to everyone else.
KC is trying to get on a burros
to help him rob a bank with the tempered
which he later tries to steal
just because he's still like in full on cry mode.
There's a funny moment
when Mobius also references his recent
escape from Alcatraz
when he's talking about sea views with Hunter B-15.
Like, Do you ever hit the water?
Because Casey literally just hit the water
when he escaped from Alcatraz.
also trying to sell Hunter B-15, a jet
ski like we have great financing options.
then they finally confirm what that monkey
was during the end credits scenes.
It's inside the record shop
the Silvie keeps going to all the time
like she's a regular there in the store.
Owners become her friend.
The owners mug of an alien abducting
someone is a reference
to Loki going around, collecting everyone
The Velvet Underground song.
He gives her to listen to is meant to be a metaphor
for everything that's happening to her right now.
And everything starts to turn into spaghetti
and disappear is a pretty decent scene.
But the weird thing is, is white.
She winds up being the last thing that turns
into spaghetti Before she steps into the portal.
Like,
why didn't she turn into spaghetti before this?
I think it's mostly just because the way
they wanted the episode to play out
But basically what we saw in all the trailers
like this brainstorm, I was breaking down,
forcing her to go back to Loki, Toby's place,
just as they all realize what's happening
and why they need to go back to the TVA,
everything starts being spaghetti fied.
Sylvie gets destroyed,
and just as Loki is about to as well,
he time slips again
and starts to be able to do it on purpose.
in as he's watching everybody disappear,
they play back dialog from season
one where he's wondering with Sylvie
about what makes an actual Loki like, Is it
because we're destined to lose as he's
losing everyone in real time here?
then he actively jumps back
a couple of moments to when Sylvie was still there
and then again on purpose
to when everyone was still there, realizing
that the secret sauce to time
slipping was by focusing on his friends.
It wasn't how or why was actually who
then uses his thoughts of then
to jump back to the moment just before Victor
timely was spaghetti fight in the TVA
control room here for the sacred timeline
and they cut to black meaning that episode six
the finale will pick up with him
trying to replay the events of the previous episode,
trying to do things differently so everybody doesn't
die in the timeline, does not blow up
There are a couple of big questions here, like
Ravena Ren Slayer is still stuck in the void Planet
Miss minutes is still going to come back
at some point during the finale.
Like she has to reboot herself.
Still, there might be a couple more scenes
with he who remains king.
And obviously,
there's going to be a bunch of new scenes
with Victor Time Lee's version of Kang,
because Loki jumped back into the past
one of the funniest moments of the episode, though,
you remember, is when Loki's eyes kind of glaze
over and confusion when Obi is trying to explain
time travel to him and how he was able to do this.
Like, theoretically, the timeline exploded.
There is no more time.
So how could you time travel if there is no time
Overall, it was a really solid episode.
Cannot wait to see how they wrap things
up in the finale in how they push into potential
Loki season three,
but obviously Avengers five, Kane Dynasty
probably a couple teasers for Deadpool
three as well too.
There's supposed to be some Deadpool three
during the Marvel's movie next week.
I'll do completely separate videos about that.
That's like a whole separate thing.
I do not think that the Marvel's movie
will be all that connected to what's happening
with Loki Season two,
even though all this is meant to lead up to Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and Avengers
six Secret Wars Overall, it was a great episode.
There are a bunch of Easter eggs
if you spotted any in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them
below in the comments I'll try to do an Episode
six finale trailer video in the next couple of days.
My full Episode six finale video will post next week
after they release it.
But there are like
a couple of really big things that also dropped
at the same time as this Loki episode.
I'm working on my Invincible Season
two Episode one video that'll post next,
and then my boys Gen V
finale video will post Saturday morning.
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
There's just a lot of really good stuff
that all just dropped at the same time.
click here for that
Loki Episode six finale video after the link.
As soon as I post that in, click here
for all my other Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!